complete the table to show equivalent
measurements in minutes and seconds so
they give us different numbers of
minutes and they ask us to figure out
how many seconds that's equivalent to
well to do this we have to remind
ourselves that there are 60 seconds in a
minute or that one minute is equal to 60
seconds and so we can just write that
right over here this first row of the
table one minute is equal to 60 seconds
now here we have three minutes so you
could really view that as three groups
of sixty seconds so if you wanted to
know how many seconds there are it's
going to be three times sixty well
what's three times sixty well three
times six is eighteen so three times
sixty is going to be a hundred eighty so
three minutes is
180 seconds
same idea for seven minutes
seven minutes times 60 seconds per
minute you're going to have to multiply
60 seconds per minute times seven
minutes which would get you well six
times seven is 42 so 60 times 7 is 420
so let me just clear that out so this is
going to be 420 and same idea 12 times 6
is 72 so 12 times 60 is 720 12 minutes
times 60 seconds per minute gives you
720 seconds